- [Voiceover] Alright,
Kim, we have 216 years
of Democratic Party history to cover,
let's cut the pleasantries
and get right to it.
Who is this man?
- [Voiceover] That is Thomas Jefferson.
- [Voiceover] He does not look like
the baby-faced boy that
he was in this image.
Is this his presidential portrait?
- [Voiceover] (laughing)
I believe so, yes.
So, Thomas Jefferson I think is really
interesting because he didn't
set out to found a party,
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Although,
he ended up doing so.
It was more that he had
a competing vision about
what the United States
should be that was different
from the vision that was being
promoted by some of the men
who were in power early
in the nation's history,
like Washington, Adams,
Alexander Hamilton.
- [Voiceover] What is the
difference between Jefferson
and Hamilton's views on governance
and how did this become
the Democratic Party?
- [Voiceover] Hamilton had
an idea that he was going
to try to make the government
a little bit more centrist,
so a strong central government,
remember they've just
switched to the constitution
from the Articles of Confederation.
- [Voiceover] What year was that?
- [Voiceover] 1787.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
- [Voiceover] And Hamilton
thinks that there needs
to be a strong central
government, a national bank,
a kind of limited democracy, right?
A democracy that is limited
to more educated, landed men,
and he wants the United States
to be a lot like England.
- [Voiceover] And Jefferson,
and people who felt like Jefferson,
like James Madison, were
saying, woah, woah, woah,
this is not what we rebelled
against England for,
to become England part two.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Instead what we should have
is very expanded democracy,
democracy for lots of people,
doesn't matter their birth,
and much more agrarian,
state-focused, small government.
- [Voiceover] And this
is what we still call
the Jeffersonian Ideal.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, yeah.
Small "r" republic citizens
who are mainly farmers.
Now, of course, the expanded democracy
that Jefferson's thinking about
doesn't apply to women
or African Americans,
Jefferson himself was a slaveholder.
But he didn't want to limit
governance to only the elite.
- [Voiceover] So, the
Jeffersonian Ideal is a republic
for all landholding citizens.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] But in 1800 the
idea of what citizen meant
was very limited and langered.
- [Voiceover] So this
doesn't really take root
until the emergence of Andrew Jackson.
In the late 1820's, he
finally gets elected in 1832.
So Jackson really pushes
the idea of democracy
for all white men to
its farthest conclusion,
which means that in this
time period he expanded
the franchise to any white man
regardless of his property,
which means that this
was the most democracy
in the history of the
world up until this point.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, but let me point out
that you did say all white men.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
So, Jackson is unabashedly a racist.
And his vision of manifest
destiny really involves
the eradication of all Native Americans.
- [Voiceover] I mean,
this is a really dark time
for American Indian policy.
This is when we see something
called the Indian Removal Act,
that is literally what it's called.
Jackson's presidency is also marked
by the Cherokee Diaspora, the
forced removal of the Cherokee
along what's called the Trail of Tears.
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- [Voiceover] So, okay.
So, before Jackson, do we really have
the Democratic Party as an institution?
- [Voiceover] No.
Before this we would've called
this the Anti-Federalists
or the Democratic Republicans.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so Hamilton
is a Federalist position.
Jefferson is an Anti-Federalist
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So, okay.
So we have these kicking
around but they're not parties
in the same way that
we would see them now,
they're just sort of policy positions?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I would say so.
Having a mass political party
was really an invention
of the Jackson era.
So, one did not run for
president in the early 1800's,
one stood for president as gentlemen
around you talked of your virtues.
It wasn't a campaign.
- [Voiceover] Oh, so you couldn't
actually campaign for yourself?
- [Voiceover] Right,
that was very uncouth.
- [Voiceover] I see.
- [Voiceover] So Jackson is
the real antidote to this.
He creates massive democracy.
The turnout in this time period
is 80, 90 percent, right?
So everybody goes to vote.
- [Voiceover] So, okay.
So, let's talk about
this political cartoon.
- [Voiceover] Well, it's
really just making fun
of Andrew Jackson for
being incredibly stubborn.
He vetoed everything because the position
of the Democratic Party,
which is founded with Jackson,
he vetoes everything because
he believes in small government.
So, he thinks that the power
of the government should
be negative, right?
The less federal power, the better.
Which is interesting
for a president, right?
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So it's in this time period,
from probably this cartoon,
that we get the image
of the donkey as the iconic
of the Democratic Party.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
- [Voiceover] Because Jack-son
many believed was a Jack-ass.
- [Voiceover] Ah.
- [Voiceover] So the Democratic Party,
as a party of all white men,
ends up having a difficult
relationship with slavery.
Which is the major issue
of 19th century America.
And the issue of slavery
really ends up kinda breaking
the Democratic Party apart
because in the election of
1860, they actually split
into the Northern Democrats
and the Southern Democrats
and run two different
candidates for president.
- [Voiceover] Woah, why?
I knew that the Whigs
were split on slavery,
what split the Democrats on slavery?
- [Voiceover] Slavery, again.
The Southern Democrats really supported
the expansion of slavery everywhere.
The Northern Democrats were just trying
to prevent the Union from breaking up.
- [Voiceover] So they were still
pro-slavery, but pro-Union?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] And that's why
they only carried Missouri?
When it says Douglas here,
is that Stephen Douglas?
- [Voiceover] That is Stephen Douglas,
famous foe of Abraham Lincoln.
- [Voiceover] Dang.
- [Voiceover] And Stephen
Douglas actually died
I think in 1861.
- [Voiceover] Woah!
- [Voiceover] Which was a real shock
for the Democratic Party because they
lost their real, major
leader in the North.
And so they are the minority
party as Abraham Lincoln
and the first Republican
leads the United States
to victory in the Civil War.
And so having been kind
of the opposition party
against the victorious
party in war means that
the Democrats are in a fairly
bad political position,
really for most of the rest
of the 19th century, right?
'Cause this is the real
ascension era of the Republicans
as they wave the bloody shirt.
- [Voiceover] So the Republican party bled
to save the Union.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] So that's your bloody shirt.
- [Voiceover] That's my bloody shirt.
- [Voiceover] It's amazing.
- [Voiceover] There it is.
Little motion blur for you.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Of waving it, okay.
I gotcha.
- [Voiceover] So, okay.
So this rhetorical strategy of saying,
hey remember, the
Republicans were the ones
that saved the Union,
that basically makes the
Democrats a rump party, right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
For the rest of the 19th century.
- [Voiceover] They're in bad shape.
But they do have a few moments,
especially in the late 19th century,
there's a major economic depression.
And remember, economic
depression is never good
for the party that's in power, right?
- [Voiceover] Right.
Is that here?
- [Voiceover] So, in the panic of 1893,
there's just major economic trouble.
And in this time period,
this is an important moment
for the Democratic Party.
- [Voiceover] Alright,
so Kim, who's this fella?
- [Voiceover] So this is
William Jennings Bryan.
- [Voiceover] Oh, I know him.
- [Voiceover] And he's one of those guys
who ran for president so many
times but never actually won.
So we don't--
- [Voiceover] Cross of Gold speech guy.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, right.
So he had this idea that the United States
should move off the gold standard
and instead allow silver as one of
the currencies backing the U.S. dollar.
And the idea behind this was that then
the money would flood into the economy,
and people would get wealthier,
and it would end this depression.
And that's not how it happened,
but what it does do is
moves the Democratic Party
in a more populist direction, taking care
of the smaller people who
need more help financially.
Right, so a more
interventionist, economic policy.
And so they want to kinda start
helping the little guy with money.
And you see this kind of in
what we would call the Progressive Era.
Which Wilson, who's gonna be
the next Democratic president,
starting in 1912, he's a big
champion of Progressivism.
And it's under Wilson's rule
that the 19th Amendment,
granting women the right
to vote, is passed.
So this is kind of
anti-corruption, anti-monopoly,
very pro trying to protect the consumer.
So this is where the sort
of more liberal aspect
of Democratic monetary policy comes from.
I don't wanna give the
impression that Progressivism
and Wilson were 100 percent good things.
On one hand, Wilson was the
first Southern president,
he was a Virginian.
Since the Civil War, after this era
of waving the bloody shirt,
and one of the things
that Wilson does is he
segregates federal jobs.
So many African Americans who were working
in the federal government
were forced out under Wilson.
- [Voiceover] And don't forget that Wilson
is the president who
screened the pro-KKK film,
"Birth of a Nation" at
the White House in 1915.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Alright, and
then World War I happened,
and then the stock market crash happened.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and the
stock market crash happened
under Republican rule, and
it's never a good thing
when your party's in power,
and there's a major economic downturn.
- [Voiceover] Right, and that's during
the Hoover Administration.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, before then.
And so it's after this economic crash
that Franklin Delano
Roosevelt comes into power.
And now Roosevelt has this very
liberal approach to economics, right?
And this is where sort of contemporary,
modern American liberalism comes from,
which is an idea that government
should regulate the economy.
You know, they shouldn't
control the economy,
but they should try to mediate some
of these major swings that
the economy could make.
And also that government
has a responsibility
for the welfare of its people.
So, FDR implements the New Deal.
Which is a really sweeping
set of social programs
designed to try to get people
out of their depression,
and guarantee a certain standard
of living for all Americans.
- [Voiceover] What are
some of those programs
from the New Deal that
we still have today?
- [Voiceover] Social Security I think
would be one of the biggest ones.
That's a living wage for the
elderly, or the disabled.
And the FDIC, the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation,
which backs banks, for example.
But what's interesting about this,
is that we often think
of the Democratic Party
and the Republican Party kind of
having opposite stances on things.
But the Democratic Party
in this time period
kinda had a liberal Northern wing,
and then a Southern conservative wing,
so there are two kind of
parts of the Democratic Party.
- [Voiceover] Sure, so
let's look at this map here,
what is this Solid South thing?
- [Voiceover] So this is the Solid South,
and the Solid South is the
Democratic, pro-Jim Crow South.
So there's the Democratic
Party in the South,
which is much smaller government,
really wanted to make sure
that African Americans
were prevented from having
political power in the South.
So it's interesting because
African Americans after FDR
really join the Democratic party,
but in the South, most of them can't vote.
- [Voiceover] Right.
It's a very uncomfortable alliance.
So, Kim, sorry, I thought that
this part of the country, the Northeast,
was still pretty solidly
Republican at this time.
- [Voiceover] I would say
that FDR puts together
kind of a New Deal
Coalition of labor unions,
ethnic and religious minorities,
sort of the workers of the United States,
who want a more interventionist
government economy.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] But don't necessarily want
the moralizing aspect
that goes along with say,
the Progressive Era, right?
The Progressives passed
prohibition, for example, right?
They thought it was morally bad to drink.
And one of the first things
FDR does when he gets
into office is to repeal
prohibition saying,
you know, what America
needs now is a drink.
Right?
So it doesn't have this moral aspect,
but it does have economic control.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] But the party
continues to kinda move
to the left on social issues,
and in the mid 1960's,
Lyndon Johnson start to pass
civil rights legislation,
like the Civil Rights Act of 1964,
and also pretty sweeping social programs,
which are called the Great Society.
So these is things like Head Start
and lots of welfare programs.
And in this time period,
along with the Civil
Rights Movement, you know,
the Democratic Party really
coalesces around this group
in the North who are
more pro-civil rights.
So this period from FDR's election
through Lyndon Johnson's administration
is really kind of the Democratic heyday
in the United States.
Save for Eisenhower, there is
no other Republican president
that's elected during this time period,
so this is 30 plus years
of Democratic ascendancy.
But it kinda comes apart in 1968.
- [Voiceover] So what happens in 1968?
- [Voiceover] Well, there's
a lot of social unrest.
The assassination of
Martin Luther King Jr.,
the assassination of Robert F. Kennedy,
many summer riots.
And many whites in the
South who had, you know,
followed this Democratic Coalition here,
began to feel that the
Civil Rights Movement
and the commitment of the Democratic Party
to civil rights had
gone too far, basically.
And there was the problem of Vietnam.
The Vietnam War, which both parties
were really strongly
anti-Communist in this time period,
so many of the sort of young people,
who might otherwise have
supported the Democratic Party,
began to feel that the
Democratic Party too
was part of this war machine that was just
sending the United States
citizens to fight a war
that they believed they
had nothing to do with.
- [Voiceover] So we're seeing
this demographic shift.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
So this Solid South, which
had been voting Democratic
because they had really
complete political hegemony,
right, 'cause African
Americans couldn't vote,
now that African Americans can vote,
many of those whites end up switching
to the Republican Party.
- [Voiceover] Interesting.
Alright, so Johnson decides
he's not even gonna run again.
- [Voiceover] Right.
'Cause he knows he can't
win because the Vietnam War
has just tarnished him in
the sight of most Americans.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So, with the
Democrats really split apart,
in complete disarray, the Republicans
take back the White House.
- [Voiceover] So, okay.
So Kim, that takes us up to about 1968
and the election of Nixon.
And there's a lot of history
of the Democratic Party.
216 years, right?
- [Voiceover] Yep, it is the oldest,
voter-based political party in the world.
- [Voiceover] So, we can't fit
the entire history into one video.
- [Voiceover] No, there's too much.
- [Voiceover] So, next
time when we come back,
we're gonna talk about
the new Democrats under President Clinton,
the Obama Administration,
and the policy and the plank
of the Democratic Party going forward.
- [Voiceover] So stay tuned.